you guys know I love talking about
political correctness and free speech
I'm trying to use my free speech while
we still have it I thought this was an
interesting story this week the
Milwaukee Art Museum is showing a
picture of the Pope entirely made out of
condoms now obviously Pope's all of them
have not been great on birth control the
Vatican has not been great on birth
control so it's actually pretty clever
satire to show a picture of the Pope all
made out of condoms pretty good now
that's sort of interesting in and of
itself but what I thought was
particularly interesting about it was
that the New York Times showed an image
of the boat made out of condoms now of
course when the Charlie Hebdo terrorist
attacks happened in France actually the
New York Times did not show the images
of Mohammed and I thought they had an
interesting quote is what they said when
they didn't show the images of Mohammed
under time standards we do not normally
publish images or other material
deliberately intended to offend
religious sensibilities after careful
consideration times addis editors
decided that describing the cartoons in
question would give readers sufficient
information to understand today's story
okay so that means that what they
decided was they work and show the
images because it was going to offend
some people now I'm pretty sure I'm not
Catholic but I'm pretty sure some
Catholic people might be offended by
their Pope being shown in condoms and
this is what the crux of political
correctness run amok is we have select
groups that were afraid to offend while
everyone knows that you could do the
thing of the Pope and no one was going
to get shot or killed and they could put
it not only in the art museum but then
put it in a newspaper and everything was
going to be fine now that's how it
should be that's how a society supposed
to be you should be able to make a lot
of absolutely everybody having satire is
one of the most important things that
any free functioning decent Western
democratic society could have and if
they had it in a lot of other places we
wouldn't see such a such craziness in
the world anyway I think it's a really
bad standard that the New York Times and
a lot of these other newspapers and
publications are showing that we pick a
group as Bill Maher refers to it it's
the soft bigotry of low expectations you
say
these guys they're actually nuts and
they're going to kill people so we're
not going to do things that upset them
but this other group we're going to do
things that obviously upset them because
we know that they won't do anything
about it I want everyone to be treated
equally as good and as shitty and I
think that's something that we all
should aspire to do